(bright music)
- McDonald's is truly an icon
of the 20th and 21st century.
- Today we are trying
bloody Aussie Macca's,
that you can only get in Australia.
- I don't know, I'm a little bit nervous.
(upbeat music)
- Oh my god.
I mean it's the beetroot
that makes it really Aussie.
- It's the beetroot, yeah.
- It's the bit of a...
(snaps fingers)
sweetness that hits you.
- If someone gave me this burger,
I wouldn't assume it was from McDonald's,
I would assume it's from the corner shop.
- A fried egg with a good piece of bacon
on top of a bit of meat,
like, that is, like,
couldn't get more Australian.
- Australians love double meat.
- It's almost now the Aussie burger but...
a little bit of sauce, 10 out of 10.
- I want Matty sauce.
- She's talking about ketchup.
- Yeah, ketchup.
(loud guitars)
- Ah, no...
- Molletes are a very
traditional Mexican breakfast.
- This is not a Mollete.
- I am ready for disappointment.
- I like it, and I don't
like regular Molletes so...
- Seems like, if you were
stoned, in another country,
and you were trying to make Molletes,
you would make this.
- Molletes are made with this
traditional Mexican bread,
called bollilo, like a really,
it's, like, sort of hard
on the outside, soft on the inside bread.
And it's like - you couldn't
do this with bollilo bread.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat guitars)
- I don't think it needs the extra bun.
- Yeah, me either.
- Can anyone really describe
what McDonald's tastes like?
- The cheese and the
vegetables, ratio is great.
But then you have this
interesting middle bun
that kind of screws everything up.
- But the funny thing is you
could take this top half off
and just eat it like a burger.
(laughs)
- My notes would be: the
middle bun, unnecessary,
but I liked it.
(upbeat music)
- Oh, okay.
- This looks interesting.
- Interesting.
- It's got all this,
all these little marks.
(Mmm)
- A little bit dry?
(laughs)
- You look like you're
about to choke on it.
The sauce on the bottom, I
don't like when they do that,
I always like my sauce on the top.
The chicken's quite nice,
there's a little bit of a kick.
- Still gonna eat it.
- But it's still a cheap burger.
- I actually got a bit of smokiness there.
I like chicken, I think it's okay.
I think I would order this again.
(exotic music)
(upbeat guitars)
- I feel like McDonald's
is like Britney Spears,
even if you deny that you don't like her,
you do like her.
- McDonald's is great,
Mexican food is great,
the both of them combined, not that much.
- You've done well McDonald's,
you're replicating good Australian life.
(upbeat guitars)
(squeaky sound effects)